our thirst for exploration has
transformed our species from nomads into
astronauts spurring new innovations
opening up the globe and clearing the
path to new and distant worlds we
explore not just to reach new lands
before the journey itself it is in the
adventure that we discover who we really
are
our discoveries about the world are
rivaled only by what has been revealed
about the human condition we are a race
of explorers we risk our lives in the
pursuit of new frontiers new experiences
and new knowledge
the spirit of discovery is built into
our biology our culture in our mythology
no man can fully grasp how far and how
fast we have come
[Music]
wherever adventure takes us in the
future whatever challenges we face we
know that the spirit of discovery will
always guide us our journey has only
just begun
we set bail on this no seals because
there is new knowledge to the game
because that goal will serve to organize
and measure the flavor the best of our
energies and skills skills because that
challenge is one that were willing to
examine Sam the best stretches of the
unknowns and the honest still far
outstrip our collective comprehension
[Music]
you